Marvel's Hulk might be the strongest
there is but he's not invincible the big
green guy and as human alter-ego Bruce
Banner have battled heroes and villains
alike a since his debut in 1962 and
while Hulk may be the strongest it's
only natural that he's still taken a few
big losses along the way here are some
more notable fights I go in the hoax owl
column but just one warning to those who
have given the Hulk a decisive beatdown
he always comes back angry and you
wouldn't like him when he's angry Thor
in 2001 Incredible Hulk annual Thor
fresh off of a battle of his own decides
to help local authorities stop the whole
to rampage the Asgardian equivalent of a
sucker punch
a thunderbolt straight to Hulk's face
gives Thor an early edge but the broad
continues across multiple dimensions
before a winner emerges ultimately
however it's those biology not as battle
prowess that puts him ahead while the
Hulk is distracted by local wildlife
Bruce Banner takes control of the Hulk's
body however the otherworldly atmosphere
doesn't have enough oxygen for a regular
human and the banner passes out leaving
Thor victorious Deadpool it's hard to
believe but in one of Deadpool's very
first the solo appearances he picks a
one-on-one fight with the Hulk and one
in 1997's deadpool number 4 Wade Wilson
learns that his healing factor is
breaking down and if that goes the
cancer that plagues his body we'll make
a quick and fatal return even worse
there's only one cure a sample of the
hoax gamma-irradiated blood tracking
down the Holt is easy getting a sample
of his blood isn't Deadpool swords don't
make much of a dent in the Hulk's thick
green hide and the Deadpool doesn't
stand a chance in a straight-up brawl
but Deadpool is not just crazy he's also
smart when the Hulk leap straight
towards him a Deadpool points an old
broken pipe right at the charging Beast
all compels himself and Deadpool
collects a blood sample from the
monsters bleeding wound before the Hulk
can recover eventually the Hulk frees
himself by pulling the pipe out of the
ground but not before Deadpool makes an
extremely speedy getaway juggernaut Cain
Marko better known as the juggernaut has
super strength and super endurance but
his most notable power is that once he's
in motion
is literally unstoppable but that
ability came in pretty handy and The
Incredible Hulk number 402 when the Hulk
took over a government agency called the
Pantheon and immediately headed to South
America on a peacekeeping mission there
Hulk ran into a casually dressed
juggernaut who immediately launched an
attack
Hulk spent most of the fight distracted
he didn't recognize Marco in everyday
clothes and yet seemed to have the
juggernaut put away when Marco sank in a
pit of quicksand but nothing can stop
the juggernaut not even mother nature
Jurgen or first out of the trap put Hulk
in a sleeper hold and went on to beat
the stuffing out of his opponent
Batman that's right Batman went
toe-to-toe with the Hulk and claimed a
victory in the process it all happened
in the DC special series number 27 an
intercompany crossover that came out in
September of 1981 using a false identity
Bruce Banner sneaks into a job at Wayne
Enterprises which was manufacturing a
brand new gamma radiation gun banner
hopes the device could get rid of the
Hulk once and for all but before he
could find out the Joker attacked
Bruce hold out just as Batman arrived
and there wasn't long before they were
both duking it out in a Wayne research
laboratory but the two of them would get
into a fight isn't surprising what is
surprising is the simplicity of Batman's
plan a pellets of sleeping gas and a
well-timed kick to the gut and the hope
Goes Down and that wouldn't be the last
time the hope faced off against a member
of Marvel's distinguished competition
Superman in 1996 the DC and Marvel
Universe is squared off in a four-part
miniseries appropriately called DC vs.
Marvel one of the series best gimmicks
was that it gave fans the ability to
vote on who would win in each
super-powered showdown while the Marvel
Universe ended up on top once the dust
cleared when Superman beat the Hulk at
the polls he laid the smackdown on the
printed page as well
it's not even close well the whole clans
a few good punches a heat vision barrage
and a well-placed strike to the jaw is
all that the last Son of Krypton needs
to put him down the only silver lining
for Hulk fans the version of the Hulk
featured in DC vs. Marvel had previously
traded some of his strength in order to
keep Bruce banners intellect but if the
whole could be No
or power maybe it would have been a
different story Hawkeye if the Hulk has
a weakness its Bruce Banner the easiest
way to put down a jade giant is to stop
banner before he transforms that's how
Hawkeye deals of the Hulk in Marvel's
crossover series Civil War two when a
young man named Ulysses prophesizes a
hog field disaster superheroes gather on
Bruce banners doorstep and asked the
scientist to turn himself in before
banner can comply however Hawkeye who
claims that he saw banners eyes flash
green lets loose an arrow killing banner
instantly but for what it's worth
banner did ask him to do it if he ever
felt he might hurt innocent people
so hooray for the good games The Hulk in
the future imperfect storylines The Hulk
takes on his own worst enemy the Hulk
and as you might guess it doesn't go so
well
that's about a hundred years in the
future future imperfect explores a world
where war has wiped out heroes and the
villains alike
the Hulk and now calling himself the
maestro rules the world with an iron
fist thanks to a combination of Bruce
Burroughs intelligence nuclear-powered
strength and a century's worth of
pent-up rage rebels use a time machine
to bring the present-day Hulk into the
future hoping that the strongest one
there can suffer warlord who's even
stronger
unfortunately the maestro knows of all
the Hulk's moves and vensim and easily
defeats his younger counterpart
ultimately snapping the Holt neck The
Hulk eventually recovers and confronts
the maestro again and while he still
can't physically defeats the despot he
does end up winning using the same time
machine that propelled him into the
future
Hulk sends a maestro back to the gamma
explosion that created him in the first
place the maestro is incinerated at the
exact same time the hulk is born leading
to a victory for the good guys and to
decisive hulk beatdowns in one epic
story now if that's not epic enough for
you strap yourself in for the hoaxes
most diabolical foe yet that's right
we're going to talk about the time the
Hulk was defeated by copies over the
years shield is tangled with the Hulk
numerous times and as one of the most
important and technologically advanced
peacekeeping agencies on the planet it
only makes sense that that put that
experience to good use
20:13 the indestructible Hulk special
shield unleashed its latest greatest and
cutest anti Hulk weapon a crate crammed
full of puppies see while the hawk might
be a monster he's not heartless the
onslaught of adorable little fur balls
'is the green Goliath nerves and force a
transformation back into the hoaxes
mild-mannered alter ego Bruce Banner not
very scientific but it got the job done
so the next time you're facing off
against the giant green rage monster
don't forget to bring a couple of cute
dog O's along thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you're loved too
[Music]